Super Bowl LVII was filled with memorable moments,
and it was great to see interpreters for
the deaf and hearing impaired for the first
time in the NFL. But did you know that you've
definitely seen one of the interpreters before?
The United States national anthem is part of
the opening of every Super Bowl. This year,
"The Star Spangled Banner"
was performed by eight-time
Grammy Award-winning country
music artist Chris Stapleton.
This year is also the first year that the
Super Bowl has included interpretation for
the deaf for the national anthem, with
the National Football League bringing in
American Sign Language interpreters to relay
Francis Scott Key's well-known lyrics. Sign
language interpretation was also provided
for Babyface's performance of "America
the Beautiful" and for Rihanna's
much-anticipated halftime show.
Babyface's performance was interpreted by
University of Arizona researcher Colin Denny,
a member of the Navajo Nation who
signed "America the Beautiful"
using a combination of A.S.L. and
North American Indian Sign Language,
which is still used by dozens of tribes to this
day. Meanwhile, African-American Philadelphia
native and Bowie State University nursing student
Justina Miles provided interpretation for both
Rihanna's performance and Sheryl Lee Ralph's
performance of "Lift Every Voice and Sing."
As for the fellow who provided sign language
for "The Star Spangled Banner," there's a good
chance you may recognize him from a variety
of movies and TV shows. If you're a fan of
"The Mandalorian," or "Scrubs," or just keep up
with recent Oscar winners, you'll recognize Troy
Kotsur. Growing up in Mesa, Arizona, and Phoenix,
Kotsur was born deaf and studied film, theater,
and television at Gallaudet University. He
established a solid career in theater and
has made appearances in several films
and television shows over the years.
In 2019, Kotsur became the first deaf actor to act
in a "Star Wars" production, when he appeared as a
Tusken raider in an episode of "The Mandalorian,"
using a Tatooine version of sign language.
"What are you doing?"
"Negotiating."
In 2022, he made history as the first deaf
male to be nominated for an Academy Award,
and, subsequently, to win an Academy Award.
Kotsur won best supporting actor for his
performance in 2021's "CODA," in which he
played a deaf fisherman attempting to come to
terms with his hearing daughter's aspirations
to become a singer. He appeared alongside
another history-maker, Marlee Matlin, who became
the first deaf person to win an Oscar for her
performance in 1986's "Children of a Lesser God."
Despite only appearing in one episode, Troy
Kotsur's contributions to "The Mandalorian"
are impressive — both as an actor and
behind-the-scenes maverick. Still,
he hasn't received the widespread
recognition he deserves due to the
fact he took on the more unsung roles. His
face wasn't shown on camera and off-camera
work tends to be overlooked in general, but his
involvement helped bring a fun scene to life.
The "Chapter 5: The Gunslinger" episode
of "The Mandalorian" sees our titular
bounty hunter encounter a pair
of Tusken Raiders on Tatooine.
He must negotiate with them for
free passage across their land,
so he communicates in their native sign language
and gets the deal done. Kotsur plays one of the
Tusken Raiders, but he's hidden behind layers
of prosthetics and unrecognizable as a result.
Kotsur also helped the show's creators come up
with the Tusken sign language. The Oscar winner
was initially brought in to help develop
a new form of sign language for the show,
so he turned to "Star Wars" lore
for inspiration as opposed to
using traditional American sign language.
For example, the sign for "Mandalorian"
was based on the shape of the character's
helmet and the 'M' handshape. As viewers,
it's easy to overlook the smaller details
that go into bringing certain scenes to life;
however, Kotsur's work actually enriched the
Tusken mythos and the "Star Wars" universe.